تناولت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز مقتل صحفيين
اخرين في غزه احدهما حمزه الدحدوح نجل
مراسل الجزيره مشيره الى ان بعض الصحفيين
قتلوا اثناء تغطيه الصراع وبعضهم عندما
كانوا في منازلهم او لجؤوا الى عائلاتهم
وفقا للجنه حمايه الصحفيين وقد ادت وفاتهم
الى صعوبه الحصول على معلومات عن حجم
القتال ومدى الدمار وهي المشكله التي
تفاقمت كذلك بسبب تدهور شبكات الاتصالات
وعدم الحصول على اذن من اسرائيل للصحفيين
الاجانب لدخول غزه في صحيفه الجارديان
مقال يحذر من ان شن هجمات بقياده الولايات
المتحده على الحوثييين في اليمن سيكون خطا
فادحا اذ سيؤدي الى تاجيج نيران صراع اكبر
في الشرق الاوسط ويشدد المقال على ان
الرده العسكريه بقياده الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا على هجمات البحر الاحمر يخاطر
بتف با قم الوضع على نطاق اوسع ومن غير
المرجح ان يجبر الحوثيين على تغيير
تكتيكاته حاله من القلق في صفوف المسؤولين
الامريكيين اشارت اليها صحيفه الواشنطن
بوست مفادها ان رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو قد يرى ان فتح جبهه قتال
موسعه مع لبنان هو مفتاح بقائه السياسي
وسط انتقادات داخليه لفشل حكومته في منع
هجوم السابع من اكتوبر تشير الصحيفه بهذا
الصدد الى تقييم استخباراتي امريكي يفيد
بانه سيكون من الصعب على اسرائيل ان تنجح
في حرب ضد حزب الله وسط القتال المستمر في
غزه صحيفه السندي تايمز تحذر من ان
الاحداث في الايام الماضيه تهدد باندلاع
حرب شامله في الشرق الاوسط قد تغطي على
المعاناه المروعه في غزه وتنقل الصحيفه عن
خبراء قولهم ان من الخطا الاعتقاد انه
بالامكان السيطره على التصعيد لانه لعبه
لا يمكن التنبؤ بها على الاطلاق والاحداث
المعقده التي تقع في الوقت نفسه تؤدي فقط
الى سوء التقدير نشرت صحيفه جروز لم بوست
مقالا بقلم الكاتبه توفا لازاروف قالت فيه
ان اسرائيل بعيده كل البعد عن الوصول الى
نقطه سيناريو اليوم التالي وفي الواقع لا
تزال تواجه فتره طويله من الفوضى في غزه
مع عدم وجود خريطه طريق واضحه بشان كيفيه
وصولها الى مرحله ما بعد الحرب في القطاع
المضطرب وفق قول الكاتبه وفي مقاله بموقع
ذا هيل قال الكاتب جوزيف روج ان
الامريكيين يستخدمون حربي العراق
وافغانستان لمحاوله الضغط على اسرائيل
لحملها على تغيير تكتيكاتها واعاده النظر
في استراتيجياتها بينما يستخدم
الاسرائيليون الحرب العالميه الثانيه
لتبرير الحرب والدفاع عن قراراتهم ويضيف
انها حاله مستعير من المقارنات ويجب ان
نتذكر انها مجرد تشبيهات وستصبح الحرب بين
اسرائيل وحماس ذات يوم بمثابه تشبيه في حد
ذاته الى صحيفتها ارتس التي طالبت في
افتتاحيتها بوقف عمليه تسليح المستوطنين
لانهاء العنف في الضفه الغربيه قائله ان
توزيع سبعه بالاف قطعه سلاح ناري على
المستوطنين منذ بدايه الحرب ادى الى تدهور
الوضع وعليه يجب ان تصبح اجراءات المراقبه
والعقاب اكثر صرامه على المستوطنين وان
تتخذ اجراءات
عمليه لحمايه السكان
الفلسطينيين